hey guys we're incredibly lucky today to
have dr. Anthony Falchi who's the
director of the allergy and infectious
disease branch of the NIH you may have
seen him on stage with Trump as he's
part of the coronavirus task force he's
gonna be answering some of our questions
today let's get right to it
how are you how's it going running away
like a maniac here but other than that
I'm good
I can only imagine I heard your wife was
forcing you to get at least four or five
hours of sleep I'm proud of her for
doing that she's the one that's doing it
it's doing it all right fair enough well
first of all let me say a huge thank you
for joining us on the YouTube channel
everyone in the YouTube community really
appreciates what you're doing my whole
channel is about fact-checking putting
out accurate info and you've essentially
become the face for that so huge thanks
from all of us for that let's start by
talking about social distancing it's
something that I've explained to my
audience that's incredibly important
that's how we control the spread of this
virus the run on hospitals there's been
a lot of talk recently about curtailing
that I'm curious not so much about the
date because as you said the virus
doesn't have a timeline what are what is
the yardstick that we're going to be
using to measure when it may be safe to
curtail the social distancing is it
number of those who are ill fatalities a
hospital preparedness what say you well
it's the combination of things and it's
going to be different through different
regions of the country because you can't
look at as uni-dimensional I mean New
York is clearly different from
Washington and it's clearly different
from Alabama but the indirect answer to
your question you look at two things you
look at the kinetics of the outbreak
when you're in the middle of an outbreak
so once it starts reaching that point of
plateauing a bit and coming down you
don't want to stop the social distancing
but you may be able to relieve the
restrictions on movement in order to get
basic supplies to people so that they're
not just locked down if you have an area
that has very few cases what you want to
do is you want to test a lot in that
area to get a feel for what the
penetrance of the virus is and when you
get an individual
case you want to immediately identify it
isolate it contact trace it and get it
out of society if you do that
efficiently you may be able to open up
that community because you're doing good
containment you know the two major
pillars are containment where you try to
stop the spread and the other is
mitigation when you say oh my goodness
it's here what are we going to do to
prevent it from getting worse do you
think that there would be any conditions
where you think politicians may act too
soon and start saying let's start
opening up some of these restrictions
what would happen in a red alert type
scenario like that
well I think that would be unfortunate
and that's the thing that we that we
advise against if you do open up too
soon you could have the perverse effect
that in as it's going this way then it
starts going back up and then you
essentially compound the need for the
kind of things respirators ventilators
hospital beds ICU things like that
you've talked a little bit about
seasonality the possibility that this
virus may go away for the summer may
return in the fall certainly not a
definite but if that were to happen what
preparations can we take as ordinary
citizens for the fall and myself as
someone who's on the frontlines as a
family medicine doctor what can we do
okay first of all if that happens and to
be honest with you I think it's going to
happen I really don't see something as
robustly transmitted as this
disappearing the way SARS did
particularly if we start to see an
increase in infections in the southern
hemisphere southern Africa places like
that now as they enter their winter
which means for sure a cycle will come
back that means that as we go down in
our cases we've got to use that time to
prepare that it doesn't happen to us to
the extent that it did the first time
around that's why we've got to do the
vaccine development that we're doing
we've got to do clinical trials in drugs
randomized control trials that prove
things work as opposed to maybe they're
going to work those are the things that
we need to do as well as get the kind of
testing capability
so that you can do good containment
without waiting until it gets into
mitigation we may have a window and it's
not going to be over we're gonna breathe
a sigh of relief when it starts to go
down
but we need to gird ourselves that it
may come back
you mentioned the clinical trials
there's hundreds of clinical trials
going on right now testing all sorts of
combinations Ram des Vere
hydroxychloroquine even plasma
transfusions are all on the table I know
that we don't have any randomized
controlled results yet do you have a
medication or treatment that you think
is a front-runner at this time well you
know we ever run this to be a trial that
we do have a randomized controlled trial
and I would hope that within the next
couple of months or less and I would say
or less we're either gonna get an
efficacy signal then we could say well
let's do it let's let it rip with that
drug or we're gonna get nothing and then
we'll say get it off the table and stop
wasting time sure but I think that's
gonna be reasonably soon okay
and also the plasma transfusions immune
globulin those kinds of things
monoclonal antibodies they're all going
to be going into testing okay I when I
meant about the randomized controlled
studies that we don't have the results
to those studies yet because that's why
it's difficult to pick a promoter we
don't have the results yeah the issue is
got not big enough yet when we get a big
enough in we'll know absolutely
we need them empowered young people they
seem to be more affected or at least
that's what the media is telling us here
in the United States is that true and if
so why here more than in China that's a
good question everybody knows that the
original China data made it look like
young people don't virtually never got
involved in a serious way then as we
start getting into Italy looking a
little bit more like us France European
countries and ourselves we're starting
to see individuals in their 30s and 40s
now if you look at them still many of
them have underlying conditions even
though they're 30 or 40 they have
diabetes they have hypertension they
have things like that but if you look
closely you will see that there are
young people who are otherwise well who
can get seriously ill so we need to
forget this that if you're young you're
good to go you have no problem there are
two issues with younger people you need
to consider a you need to avoid
infection just like everybody else
not only for your own health but even if
you get triple e involved you can be a
vector that would ultimately infect
someone who does have a real risk of
serious conditions it's kind of like the
young healthy 25 year old gets infected
goes home infects grandma and grandpa or
a 40 year old uncle who has metastatic
disease on chemotherapy that's the
problem there's been some talk about the
possibility of reinfection with kovat 19
now do you think that this is more an
issue with testing that the test remains
positive or are they truly being
infected for a second time with the
virus you know I don't know the answer
to that 100% but I would be willing to
bet on my experience and I'll bet your
experience that any virus that you have
if you do well recover and clear the
virus if it acts like any other virus
you're gonna have lasting immunity
you're not gonna get reinfected yeah the
way the way that I've thought about it
is there's certain illnesses where you
get lifelong immunity chicken pox
measles with your two vaccinations so
maybe this won't be lifelong immunity
but to say there is none where you can
get reinfected in two weeks something
seems off
no that's inconceivable to me but that's
the case I mean you're gonna have some
degree of durable immunity you're right
it may not be 50 years but it's
certainly gonna be a matter of a few
years for myself as a healthcare
provider this is something my hospital
system even asked me to ask you when is
it safe for us to return to work once
we've either tested positive for kovat
19 or you know with the lack of testing
kits had an upper respiratory viral
illness where we don't know if it was Co
vat19 when can we return is it when
fever subsides 24 hours after fever
subsides or do we do a full 14-day or 21
day quarantine if you are a healthcare
provider or someone who is in a critical
infrastructure and you need to get back
to work to assume that you're infected
what you can do is that you can wear a
mask take your temperature daily monitor
yourself if you get symptoms get out of
circulation
if
not assume you're infected but do it in
a way where you don't affect anybody
else otherwise every one of our health
care providers are getting exposed every
day they can't assume they're infected
they've just got to go to work and
that's one of the things we're gonna be
recommending makes sense that brings me
to the topic of personal protective
equipment and 95 masks as recently as
last week my hospital was in need of
these donations I actually went on a
journey to purchase $50,000 worth of
masks myself from construction workers
and was able to donate them why do you
think there's such a shortage obviously
there's huge demand because we need to
constantly be using these masks New York
Presbyterian Hospital system they use
forty to seventy thousand masks a day
but do you also think there's an issue
of hoarding here or some sort of customs
issue of getting these masks shipped
over it's a combination of all of the
above so one of the things that we've
really got to get away from was we gotta
bake testing in a way that doesn't have
the tester consumed PPE PPE should be
for the people who are taking care of
sick patients and right now we've got to
have a system where a person could self
stick the swab in put it in the vial
give it to somebody and nobody puts PPE
on so you don't waste it that's the
first thing the second thing we've got
to keep manufacturing it at a very very
high level I mean there was no
anticipation that it would be so many
people would need this so we've got to
get people who don't need it to not use
it and we got to get a lot more for the
people who need it
speaking of those types of quick testing
for point-of-care testing for those
rapid tests do you see that coming
sooner rather than later for us in the
family practice setting we have the
influenza swabs that in 15 minutes we
have an answer is there something like
that on the horizon yeah I mean I was at
the you know I go to these tests force
meetings at the White House every day
yeah I was at one last evening that was
a topic of conversation how are we gonna
scale these up and get these going I
can't give you a timeframe but there's a
lot of enthusiasm about getting the
private sector to really scale that up
America and Italy seem to be
disproportionately affected to other
nations that are even closer to Wuhan
China which seems to be the epicenter of
their original epicenter of this
why do you think that this happened here
in the US and in Italy so much so than
other nations well you know I think
because people travel here and travel to
Europe and Italy a lot I think we really
saved ourselves a real bad bullet if you
want to call that by very quickly
shutting down the influx of cases from
China and then something that was very
controversial you might remember when we
shut down influx from Europe because you
know Europe is the new China there's
some numbers that you may be aware of
that are really extraordinary about 60%
of all the infections now you know in
new if you took about New York City how
we're getting influx from from from from
other countries particularly China
that's how New York got hit so badly New
York I mean I mean I'm a New Yorker in
case you have a save for my accent but
you know about 56% of the new infections
right now in our country are in New York
City New York City has more than half of
the action it's a big city it's a robust
city people come and go I think that's
the reason why the United States is
getting hit because the kind of country
we are it makes sense and I you know I
live a few blocks away from Times Square
my windows actually look at Times Square
and I think there's also a statement
something to celebrate the fact that
there's so much solidarity this past
Saturday 9:00 p.m. there wasn't a soul
in Times Square the fact that we are
coming together doing the social
distancing is not something talked about
in media and I think it should be
highlighted we are doing a good job
especially under these crazy
circumstances would you agree I totally
agree I I was gonna say I am amazed but
that's the wrong word I'm impressed
proud I shouldn't be amazed because the
American spirit is amazing yeah but in
fact what I see here in Washington DC is
the same thing I mean people are doing
things in a calm way that I just think
is wonderful yes really is agree and my
final question is any guidance for us as
physicians and what role do you think it
plays in filling out death certificates
I fill these out before for my patients
when I have done death pronouncements as
a resident
and you know if a patient has CHF they
come in with a congestive heart failure
exacerbation but they also have a viral
illness at the time what should go on
the death certificate is a clinical
judgment and what role do you think that
plays in the numbers you know I think
it's gonna influence the numbers I think
you got to make it clear if someone
obviously goes into it with the acute
respiratory distress syndrome and dies
on an uneventful Aitor
you know that's coronavirus disease you
got to make sure it gets on to the death
certificate okay yeah because I've seen
countries that have been having low
numbers of kovat 19 mortality but then
their numbers of pneumonia cases spiked
and it's are you just changing what's on
the death certificate there and that's
impacting those numbers right all right
well thank you so much dr. foutch you
very much appreciate your time and
everything you've done for our nation
you're a voice of reason and a much
needed time thank you it's very much of
a pleasure to be with you keep up your
good work thank you in the trenches is
important keeping up doctor foul she's
amazing at fact-checking
especially presidents he served six of
them now I tried my hand at
fact-checking politicians click on the
video here or if you want to have a good
laugh and click here